[Music]
you have noticed something on the web
yes which is the comments is that right
oh yeah yeah well here's the thing so we
have this youtube channel and and web
video youtube is really
like there hasn't been a paradigm shift
like this since the industrial
revolution like it is it has empowered
the people it's one of the most
important things that we have as a
community and yet if you've ever been to
the comment threads of a web video yeah
it is the taint of humanity like the
worst
it is made of spiders and hatred and i
don't understand where it's like a
comment on a youtube video is basically
the equivalent of saying i am 13 and i
am currently unattended like it is the
worst
you could you could show you could post
a video of like a puppy rescuing a baby
from a fire and delivering it to its
mother and the first comment would be
like sucks like it's getting worse yes
yeah and the second one would rate the
dog's performance and the third one
would be horribly racist but then the
fourth comment
the fourth comment is always like hey
guys jesus is lord i don't know why
someone always takes it
in the comment threads
always